Movies take a staggering amount of money to
make, and nowadays, any budget below $50 million
is considered mid-to-low range.
That level of spending usually works out in
the end, since movies also make a staggering
amount of money, but not all producers are
lucky enough to earn back their investment.
In the case of these films, the films did
so poorly at the box office that they're considered
cautionary tales in Tinseltown.
The 13th Warrior
Adapted from a Michael Crichton novel, The
13th Warrior is loosely based upon the myth
of Beowulf.
While the film earned some recognition for
its expensive set pieces, those costly moments
ended up ballooning the film's budget to $160
million, while the box office returns were
only $61.7 million, leaving the film with
a deficit of almost $100 million.
The movie's failure to find an audience is
a bit of a puzzler, since the source material
was by a proven bestselling writer and it
was directed by Die Hard's John McTiernan.
But no matter the reason, the end results
were so embarrassing that co-star Omar Sharif
ended up briefly retiring from acting in disgust.
The Adventures of Pluto Nash
Eddie Murphy used to be a reliable hit-maker
with successes in everything from action adventure
films to zany comedies to movies that required
him to suit up for almost every character.
He even had some successes on the family film
scene with Dr. Doolittle and Shrek confirming
that kiddos liked to laugh at him just as
much as adults.
But his star power burnt out somewhere between
those films and The Adventures of Pluto Nash,
because the film earned back just $7.1 million
of its $100 million budget.
It's not hard to see why the film fared so
poorly.
With mediocre special effects, a confusing
and unfunny script, and a nonsensical future
setting, even Eddie Murphy's big name couldn't
save the film from flopping hard.
Stealth
Rob Cohen was behind the lens for a number
of hits, including The Fast and the Furious
and xXx.
But his box office streak took a serious nosedive
when his aviation actioner Stealth crashed
and burned at the box office.
The film followed a crew of Air Force pilots
trying to control an Artificial Intelligence
jet.
But instead of being a compelling adventure
movie, it was more like a science-fiction
parody of Top Gun.
It grossed just $76 million against a $135
million budget and made good on its title
by sneaking away from the theaters largely
unnoticed.
Sahara
Based on a massively successful series of
books about a rugged adventurer with a quick
wit and a way with women, Sahara looked like
it might be able to recapture the magic of
Indiana Jones.
Unfortunately for everyone involved, the built-in
audience for the books didn't translate to
a box office success and Sahara grossed a
modest $119.3 million that wasn't enough to
cover its $160 million budget and $81 million
in distribution costs.
Part of it could have just been poor timing,
since the movie starred Matthew McConaughey
before his star power returned in full force
with the McConaissance.
"It'd be a lot cooler if you did."
But either way, the studio was parched after
this movie's returns.
Mars Needs Moms
Disney's experiment with motion-capture performance,
co-produced by legendary director Robert Zemeckis,
seemed like a good idea on paper.
And Mars Needs Moms wasn't conceptually off
the mark, either, as it followed a nine-year-old
trying to save his mom from aliens who want
to harness her powers to juice up their "nannybots,"
which is the stuff of fairly standard family
fare.
But while the film's effects were cutting
edge, they gave an almost uncomfortable eeriness
to every character's facial expressions.
And rather than an exciting adventure or a
surreal nightmare of a film, the movie ended
up being a snooze.
Audiences on Earth didn't have much interest
in it, handing over just $39 million in ticket
fare against a whopping $150 million budget.
The Mouse House might not usually have trouble
wrangling in the kiddos to see their animated
features, but this movie marked a major write-down
for the studio.
Speaking of Disney flops in outer space ...
John Carter
Based on the seminal works of Edgar Rice Burroughs,
which influenced everything from Star Wars
to parts of the DC Universe, John Carter seemed
like a sure thing on paper.
In practice, though, the film fet ironically
derivative and trite.
John Carter managed to make $73 million domestically,
with worldwide sales barely pushing the film
past its $250 million budget.
Considering it took around $100 million more
to market the movie, Disney took a hefty loss
on the would-be tentpole project.
The title hero of the film might be less affected
by gravity on Mars, but here on Earth, he
was brought down hard.
R.I.P.D.
The title of this film is an acronym for the
Rest In Peace Department, a special police
force that takes care of renegade spirits
before they can affect the human world.
It's basically Men in Black with a supernatural
twist, and the casting of Ryan Reynolds as
the upstart partner to Jeff Bridges' grumpy
mentor seemed like a no-brainer.
Unfortunately, the movie was pronounced D.O.A.,
barely making back $78 million of its $130
million budget.
While the failure of certain films can sometimes
be attributed to poor marketing, studio interference,
or even rival movie releases that are oddly
similar, the blame for R.I.P.D. rests pretty
entirely on the film itself—it's relentlessly
unfunny.
Bridges and Reynolds seem like they're so
bored with the script that they might as well
be on the other side.
But, hey, maybe they were just method acting
the whole time.
"tough day."
The Lone Ranger
The character The Lone Ranger is a classic
part of American pop culture.
Unfortunately for the makers of the 2013 reboot
of the hit TV and radio series, however, the
film was plagued with problems from start
to finish.
For starters, the film drew ire over casting
Johnny Depp as the Native American sidekick
Tonto, which prompted massive criticism over
its decision to whitewash the character.
Then, there was the matter of its bloated
budget, which was $215 million before marketing
costs.
And to top it all off, critics laughed at
the film for all the wrong reasons.
"Justice is what I seek kemosabe"
Maybe just... pick a different hat next time.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!